bonjour Jean-Luc gaise bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous présidez
le département de la Gironde et vous
êtes le chef de fil du groupe de gauche
dans cette assemblée des départements de
France on va évidemment parler des
enjeux de ce congrès dans quel état
d'esprit vous êtes ce matin ici à
Strasbourg au moment de la clôture de ce
congrès d'abord très offensif avec la
volonté évidemment de d'attirer
l'attention de madame la Première
ministre sur la situation des
départements et donc en attente aussi
des annonces qui pourraient être faites
ce matin nous attendons beaucoup de sa
venue au niveau de ce congrès qu'est-ce
que vous attendez précisément qu'est-ce
que doit dire ellisabeth borne pour que
vous sortiez satisfait d'abord une
reconnaissance de la pertinence et de
l'utilité des département comme une
collectivité de proximité ensuite le
fait qu'aujourd'hui la situation
financière est terrible dans les
départements puisque nous sommes privés
de toute autonomie fiscale et que nous
n'avons plus que pour possibilité de
pilotage financier de jouer sur nos
dépense donc d'économiser au maximum
donc il faut véritablement que cette
situation soit prise en compte et que
nous retrouvions à la fois notre
autonomie financière et surtout une
autonomie ensuite d'action publique au
service de nos populations que vous
n'avez pas vous n'avez pas aujourd'hui
ce pouvoir d'agir comme le disaient les
maires de France non on disait gouverner
c'est prévoir mais aujourd'hui la
question c'est gouverner c'estes
pouvoirs et donc il faut que nous
puissions et pour cela il nous faut les
moyens pour être à la hauteur de nos
compétences donc un message et euh on
imagine que vous attendez des mesures
concrètes notamment sur le plan
financier oui tout à fait mais l'idée
c'est que ce ne soit pas forcément que
des mesures pansement avec euh à chaque
fois des enveloppes qui peuvent être
données ici ou là que l'on prend bien
évidemment mais il faudrait
véritablement un changement structurel
pour garantir que les départements
puissent être à la hauteur de leur
mission donc c'est-à-dire que vous
voulez pas des enveloppes euh
financières mais que vous voulez des
recettes qui soient dynamiques oui c'est
ça nous prenons en tout cas les
enveloppes évidemment par défaut pour
l'instant la réalité aussi c'est que les
recettes que reçoivent les départements
qui ont des missions de solidarité sont
ont des recettes qui sont adossées au
marché les droits de mutation et ensuite
la TVA il nous semble qu'il n'y a pas
forcément de pertinence sur enfin de
cohhérence en tout cas entre les
recettes et les dépenses donc nous
demandons des dépens des recettes qui
soient beaucoup plus en phase peut-être
une part par exemple de la CSG allez on
va rentrer dans le détail de ces
questions et notamment revenir sur les
questions financières mais le sujet qui
est peut-être au cœur de ce congrès
c'est la question des mineurs étrangers
isolés qui est un défi aujourd'hui pour
les départements tous ne peuvent pas y
faire face le Sénat examine en ce moment
même le projet de loi immigration on a
entendu les sénateurs monter au créneau
sur ce sujet est-ce que pour vous il
manque dans ce texte du Gouvernement des
mesures concrètes pour vous aider à
faire face à la question des mineurs
étrangers isolés alors d'abord je ne
suis pas certain que ce soit le
principal sujet des assises aujourd'hui
je crois que le sujet c'est vraiment la
situation de département attention aussi
à l'appellation ce sont des mineurs non
accompagnés c'est un statut spécifique
qui à ce moment-là place les enfants
sous protection des des départements
alors aujourd'hui i le sujet c'est
d'arriver à faire face effectivement au
besoins d'accueil de ces enfants une
fois qu'ils sont reconnus MNA je crois
que le sujet c'est aussi la question
financière c'est-à-dire si nous avons
les recettes pour faire face à la prise
en charge de ces enfants il n'y a plus
de sujet aujourd'hui les départements
qui sont en difficulté sont les
départements qui ont du mal à accueillir
ces jeunes en plus de tous les autres
jeunes que l'on doit accueillir parce
qu'ils n'ont pas en face les recettes
nécessair est-ce que là-dessus
département de droite et département de
gauche vous avez une position unanime où
il y a des
non il y a il y a des visions
différentes d'abord nous pensons nous
que les MNA sont des enfants à prendre
en charge tout à fait comme les autres
et qu'à ce titre il n'y a qu'une
protection de l'enfance certains
départements de droite ont exprimé le
fait qu'ils souhaitaient avoir une une
aide sociale à l'enfance se différencié
pour les mineurs en accompagnés par
rapport à tous les autres enfants nous
pensons que c'est un élément de
discrimination qui ne nous paraît pas
satisfaisant à gauche on va revenir
là-dessus on va écouter parce qu'il en a
il en est beaucoup questions au Sénat il
en a été été question hier en séance
mais il en a également été question lors
de la séance de question d'actualité au
Gouvernement et on va écouter ce qu'a
répondu au sénateur la ministre en
charge des collectivités Dominique fort
un enfant isolé sur le territoire
français doit quel que soit sa
nationalité être protégé le doigt
français consacre explicitement ce
principe c'est pourquoi tout mineur non
accompagné confié à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance laaz est pris en charge dans
les mêmes conditions que les enfants de
nationalité française depuis
l'État soutient les départements à
travers un dispositif de répartition
équilibré des MNA sur le territoire mais
aussi une aide financière pour compenser
une partie des coûts liés à leur prise
en charge la loi du 7 février 2022 a
fait évoluer la prise en charge des MNA
au bénéfice de tous pour protéger les
enfants mais aussi parce que cela arrive
lutter contre les abus et réprimer ceux
qui ne respectent pas les règles depuis
ce printemps nous avons renforcé les
moyens à la frontière et dans les
services de l'État dans les Alpes mari
te particulièrement qui ont été les plus
touchés le préfet a réquisitionné des
locaux nous avons proposé une aide pour
évaluer ces mineurs début septembre le
gouvernement a lancé une enquête flash
pour faire un état des lieux des
difficultés de prise en charge rencontré
par les départements et en tirer les
leçons sur cette base avec Charlotte
cobel avec Gérald armanin avec Éric
Dupont Moretti autour de madame la
Première ministre nous travaillons à des
solutions de moyen et de long terme
Jean-Luc gise vous êtes d'accord avec la
première partie du discours de la
ministre sur la prise en charge qui doit
revenir au département et vous êtes un
peu plus sceptique quand elle dit qu'il
y a les moyens alors d'abord il y a deux
choses avant qu'un jeune soit évalué MNA
il y a une période de mise à l'abri qui
correspond à une période d'évaluation
nous pensonsnous que la mise à l'abri
est de compéten de l'État voire même
l'évaluation qui pourrait être de
compéten de l'État puisqu'elle est
hantée définition du statut de MNA après
concernant les moyens il y a des moyens
qui sont déployés mais par exemple la
mise à l'abri pour l'instant n'est
financée que sur 5 jours alors qu'elle
du beaucoup plus longtemps sauf que ce
que vous répond Charlotte cobel en
charge de la protection de l'enfant
c'est elle veut pas de découpage de la
protection de l'enfant c'est que si
l'état reprend à sa charge la mise à
l'abri le temps de l'évaluation et bien
elle s prête à envisager une
recentralisation de la protection de
l'enfance comment vous avez pris ces
propos alors j'ai eu Charlotte cobel en
direct qui me dit ne pas avoir exprimé
le souhait de recentralisation donc
c'est à elle qu'il revientne de son
exprimer en revanche je pense que tout
ce qui est le travail avant l'évaluation
doit relever de l'État et ensuite une
fois que l'enfant est reconnu mineur non
accompagné il entre dans le champ
universel du droit de la protection de
l'enfance et donc à ce titre nous le
prenons en charge il y a il y a un autre
sujet c'est que la loi portée par Adrien
taquet en février 2002 interdit au
département la prise en charge de ces
mineurs non accompagné dans les hôtels
lorsqu'ils ont moins de 16 ans est-ce
que il faut revenir sur cette
disposition non je pense que c'est une
question de de dignité dans l'accueil
même si les départements qui sont
obligés de faire un accueil en hôtel gar
antis un accompagnement associé
néanmoins je pense que là aussi c'est
une question de moyen il faut pouvoir
ouvrir les places nécessaires et pour
cela il faut que les départements
disposent des recettes ad hoc il y a pas
de risque de saturation aujourd'hui pour
les départements de saturation
d'hébergement des départements qui
disent qu'ils ne sont pas en mesure de
placer tous ces jeunes je crois que la
situation des départements peut-être
très différente entre un département
comme les Alpes Maritimes par exemple ou
l'il Villen et d'autres départements qui
sont beaucoup moins sujets en Gironde
par exemple c'est ce n'est seulement que
10 % de la protection de l'enfance qui
est concerné par les MNA donc je crois
que les situations sont très variables
mais en tout cas je pense c'est une
prise en charge globale que doit avoir
l'État au titre d'une attention à
l'égard des départements on va revenir à
la question des finances hein puisque
vous le dites c'est également évidemment
un sujet d'inquiétude pour les
départements vous attendez des mesures
d'éliisabeth born notamment une
enveloppe le gouvernement qui a de qui
s'est de nouveau engagé cette année à
augmenter la dotation globale de
fonctionnement qui est la principale
dotation des collectivités c'est la
deuxème année de suite qu'elle augmente
est-ce que vous vous saluez cette
décision et est-ce que c'est la preuve
que le gouvernement prend en compte les
problèmes des collectivités alors je
saluerai mieux cette revalorisation si
elle était conforme à celle de
l'inflation le problème c'est que le
pourcentage d'évalu dévolution de la DGE
aujourd'hui de la DGF pardon est
inférieur au à l'évolution de
l'inflation donc on a un delta qui fait
qu'en réalité le complément de moyen qui
nous est apporté n'est pas à la hauteur
des charges que nous avons assumé au
titre de l'énergie au titre des fluides
de toutes les hausses en matière
d'inflation que nous devons subir donc
il manque encore quelque chose pour
aller être à la hauteur vééritablement
de mais AUG ce qui n'était pas le cas
depuis des années oui tout à fait non
mais c'est c'est très bien moi je je
prends tout à fait toute augmentation de
la de la DGF néanmoins elle n'est pas
suffisante pour couvrir véritablement
l'impact de l'inflation et vous nous
disiez vous alliez demander ellisabeth
borne que les départements reçoivent une
part de la CSG c'est votre demande en
tout cas que nous ayons une une réponse
en recette structurelle qui soit
permanente dans le temps et qui soit
plus adapté à la réalité des missions
que nous accomplissons aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans le champ de la solidarité et
nous avons des recettes qui sont liées
au marché je trouve qu'il n'y a pas de
cohérence il faut trouver une recette
adaptée mais il faut surtout l'inscrire
dans le temps long pour répondre au
besoins des départements quelle
conséquen aujourd'hui pour les
départements pour un département comme
le vôre par exemple de cette
augmentation des coûts liés notamment
évidemment à l'inflation qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire c'est moins
d'investissement c'est moins de service
public alors très clairement nous
diminuons les investissements voire même
nous en arrêtons une partie donc
conséquence sur l'économie et sur
l'emploi
ensuite nous sommes en train de sabrer
dans un certain nombre de politiques
publiques ce sont des choix difficiles à
opérer et donc ce sont aussi des
dégradations de services publics pour
nos concitoyens je pense que ça n'est
pas la bonne manière de faire on ne peut
pas piloter des budgets départementaux
sur la dépense il faut impérativement
que nous puissions disposer des recettes
mais concrètement aujourd'hui pour les
gens qui nous regardent qu'est-ce que
vous ne pouvez plus faire pour eux et
que vous faisiez avant alors très
clairement aujourd'hui dans les
questions il y a les aides dans les
politiques dites volontaristes qui sont
souvent des politiques de lien social le
monde de la culture le monde du sport
les actions éducatives dans les collèges
mais ça peut-être aussi revoir le
montant attribué par exemple à des épad
le montant attribué à des services
d'aide à domicile donc ce sont vraiment
toucher les services fondamentaux que
doivent pter les départements et ça
c'est un déchirement pour nous ouis
parce qu'il y a un autre sujet c'est que
vous avez en charge les ce qu'on appelle
les allocations individuelles de
solidarité là aussi avec un reste à
charge qui est énorme pour les
départements vous demandez là aussi des
réponses Élisabeth borne mais même si on
a l'impression que ça fait des années
que cette question se pose oui alors
nous sommes un niveau de collectivité
qui opère en péréquation horizontale
nous reversons une partie de nos
recettes entre les départements plus
riches et plus pauvres sur les dépenses
nous avons un un reste à charge qui est
énorme effectivement c'est la solidarité
nationale qui s'existe qui qui s'exerce
c'est donc l'état qui doit permettre
d'être à hauteur de ce que doit être la
solidarité nationale nous nous aurions
des budgets dans ce cas qui seraient
beaucoup plus confortables et qui nous
permettrai de maintenir nos services
publics ce qui n'est pas le cas avec un
reste à charge qui s'accroit oui tout à
fait qui s'est accru au fil des années
depuis déjà un certain nombre d'années
et qui aujourd'hui devient tellement
pesant que nous n'avons plus la capacité
de faire face correctement à nos
dépenses et là aussi je vous pose la
question des conséquences est-ce qu'il y
a des conséquences notamment pour les
éepads il peut y avoir des conséquences
pour les éepades ça va dépendre des
choix que vont opérer les différents
départements et de la situation en 2024
mais en tout cas aujourd'hui il y a des
choix difficiles qui rentrent dans les
compétences obligatoires des
départements alors que nous devrions
être à la hauteur des missions qui nous
sont confiées il y a un autre sujet
c'est la question de la décentralisation
Emmanuel Macron dimanche a écrit au chef
de parti pour les convier à une nouvelle
rencontre de Saint-Denis et notamment il
a fait plusieurs propositions sur la
question du référendum mais aussi sur la
décentralisation il a confié une mission
à Eric vert sur la simplification du
millefeuille territoriale est-ce que
c'est la bonne méthode alors d'abord
pourquoi reposer la question de la
décentralisation ça sous-entend qu'elle
ne fonctionne pas en tout cas moi je
pense que l'évaluation à 40 ans est
intéressante parce que ça nous permet de
voir si elle est toujours adaptée au
temps présent le contenu de la lettre
par contre nous a fait réagir parce
qu'elle est très technocratique il n'y a
pas de souffle et d'ambition politique
on ne sait pas ce que veut véritablement
le président de la République or c'est
ce qu'il devrait exprimer dans une
lettre de mission et puis après il nous
reviendra de travailler éventuellement
sur la mise en œuvre opérationnelle mais
en tout cas nous estimons nous qu'elle
est elle n'est pas rédigée correctement
nous ferons peut-être la proposition
d'ailleurs d'être accompagnateur pour
rédiger une nouvelle lettre de mission
d'Eric ver de manière à faire en sorte
qu'elle soit plus en phase avec une
ambition politique sur la décentralisé
donc vous demandez à Eric verd de vous
consulter de dialoguer avec les
départements avant de commencer ses
travaux avant de lancer sa feuille de
route écoutez je pense que la moindre
des choses quand on prétend s'occuper
des collectivités locales c'est d'abord
d'aller les trouver pour voir si tout
cela correspond bien et voir si comment
on peut adapter la démarche à ce
moment-là et faire en sorte qu'elle
corresponde véritablement un
questionnement sur qu'est-ce que la
décentralisation aujourd'hui et comment
faut-il l'améliorer sauf que Emmanuel
Macron il parle également de
simplification d'un grand nombre d'un
trop grand nombre de strates est-ce que
vous êtes inquiet que ça touche les
départements et que les départements
soient encore en danger mais moi je ne
comprends pas la question de départ
pourquoi partir sur des question de
strat aujourd'hui quel est le bon niveau
de collectivité locale pour le bon
niveau d'action publique et à ce titre
je trouve que chaque niveau y compris
l'État a des compétences qui qui lui
sont attribuées et peut les exercer
ensuite à condition d'en avoir les
moyens la question n'est pas de
supprimer une une strate c'est
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui ne fonctionne
pas éventuellement dans la
décentralisation et à partir de là
tironsen les enseignements pour y
trouver les solutions là on est en train
d'essayer de cibler une solution avir
même d'avoir réalisé le diagnostic sur
l'état de la décentralisation
aujourd'hui donc je pense que ça n'est
pas la bonne méthode et ça n'est pas le
bon point d'entrée mais qu'est-ce qui ne
fonctionne pas il faut quoi une
clarification des compétences est-ce que
vous demandez-vous des compétences
supplémentaires je je crois que nous
demandons à ce que l'État d'abord soit à
la hauteur de ses compétences sur le
plan régalien aujourd'hui nous assumons
nous des dépenses dans les département
qui relève des dépenses normalement de
l'État donc déjà que l'État assume ses
responsabilités et ensuite regardons
comment chacun dispose des moyens pour
pouvoir véritablement être à la hauteur
de ses compétences c'est vraiment la
question du bon niveau de collectivité
pour le bon niveau d'action publique
avec les moyens associés y compris au
niveau de l'État mais François sauvadé
il pose la question lui de la pertinence
des régions est-ce que vous aussi vous
qui qui êtes dans une région énorme la
nouvelle Aquitaine est-ce que vous posez
aussi la question de la pertinence des
régions est-ce qu'il faut revoir ce
redécoupage territorial mais moi j'ai
pas envie d'opposer les collectivités
moi je crois que la manœuvre derrière la
lettre de mission c'est aussi de semer
une pomme de discorde entre les
collectivités locales et je pense que
nous avons intérêt à être très groupés
entre nous pour défendre avant tout une
république décentralisé région avec leur
mission département avec leur mission
commune avec leur mission et l'État qui
doit assumer les siennes pleinement pour
que tout le monde soit à sa place avec
les moyens adaptés et on verra ce que
vous répond ellisabeth borne un dernier
mot peut-être pour finir sur une
question d'actualité évidemment qui
touche tous les Français dimanche Gérard
larch et elbon pivé ont appelé à une
marche civique pour lutter contre
l'antisémitisme il y a plus de 1000
actes antisémites qui ont été commis
depuis le 7 octobre en un mois c'est
trois fois plus que l'année dernière
comment comment on lutte contre cette
résurgence de l'antisémitisme comment on
le on lutte contre cette résurgence de
l' d'abord je crois que le fait de
pouvoir affirmer que la République
française refuse des actes antisémite
est fondamental et donc je pense que
toute manifestation qui permet
d'apporter un soutien est absolument
nécessaire après je pense que c'est une
véritable question d'éducation de
sensibilisation d'ouverture au monde et
d'ouverture à l'autre et ça ce sont
toutes les actions éducativ pédagogique
qui doivent être mis en place pour
rappeler que dans notre pays qui est un
pays des droits de l'homme nous devons
respecter l'égalité la fraternité éviter
le racisme et l'antisémitisme
impérativement est-ce qu'il y a aussi un
rôle de la classe politique dans cette
lutte contre l'antisémitisme oui est-ce
que vous les la classe politique les
élus locaux vous avez un rôle à jouer
bien sûr c'est un rôle aussi dans la
proximité que nous avons d'explications
permanentes sur le fait qu'il ne faut
pas discriminer stigmatiser des
personnes en fonction de leur provenance
en fonction de leur origine ou en
fonction de leur religion est-ce que la
la toute la classe politique selon vous
est suffisamment unie dans cette lutte
contre l'antisémitisme écoutez en tout
cas j'espère qu'elle l'est nous sommes
toutes et tous élus républicains la
République encore une fois porte des
valeurs et nous devons nous les premiers
défendre ses valeurs donc j'en fais
partie et j'espère en tout cas que tout
le monde a bien compris la nécessité
impérative de lutter contre
l'antisémitisme c'est le cas quand vous
voyez parce que vous savez pourquoi je
vous pose la question he quand Gérard
Larché et elbrun pivé ont annoncer cette
marche civique contre l'antisémitisme on
a vu quelques minutes après la réaction
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon dire les amis du
soutien inconditionnel au massacre on
leur rendez-vous comment vous réagissez
face à ce message je je pense que c'est
une une provocation complètement
détournée dévoyée par rapport à la
réalité du sujet la réalité du sujet
c'est qu'il n'est pas possible
aujourd'hui que des que des étoiles de
David soit dessiné sur les murs de de
maisons privées pour stigmatiser des
personnes comme l'étoile jaune a pu le
faire à une certaine époque avec les les
nazis donc ça c'est absolument
inadmissible et là je pense que ce
combat doit être absolument consensuel
et commun pour toutes et tous vous qui
êtes un élu de gauche hein Jean-Luc
glise un élu socialiste est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui les prises de position de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon sont un problème pour
la gauche écoutez quand elles sont
provocquantes oui elles le sont après je
connais des gens dans la France
insoumise qui sont des gens respectables
et qui peuvent avoir la modération et la
et la correction nécessaire lorsqu'il y
a de la provocation elle ne m'intéresse
pas je pense que ça n'est pas le rôle
d'élu de la République que de provoquer
ainsi que le fait Jean-Luc Mélenchon
mais est-ce que ça abîme la gauche B
écoutez j'espère que ça n'abîme pas
celles et ceux qui sont raisonnables et
qui sont profondément républicains en
tout cas nous nous portons une voix qui
est une voix de respect une voix de
raison et nous continuerons à la porter
au niveau du Parti socialiste depuis les
prises de de position de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon le Parti socialiste a acté un
moratoire sur sa participation à laanupe
a pris ses distances du coup avec la
France insoumise est-ce que ce moratoire
peut durer jusqu'à quand et est-ce qu'à
un moment il faut fermer la porte quand
on voit les prises de positions répété
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon écoutez moi je
pense que aujourd'hui je porte la voix
d'un parti qui est celui du Parti
socialiste je ne porte pas la voix de la
totalité de la gauche donc à chacun de
rester à sa place et d'agir en en
conséquence et en responsabilité et nous
jugerons au fil des mois ce qui se passe
en tout cas moi il y a un certain nombre
de réactions que je n'approuve pas et
que je continuerai à désapprouver y
compris publiquement merci Jean-Luc
glise